tengo 10 compromisos
primero
trabajaré para conseguir la paz
verdadera y definitiva
como nadie como nunca vamos a cumplir el
acuerdo de paz y a seguir las
recomendaciones de la comisión de la
verdad el gobierno de la vida es el
gobierno de la paz la paz es el sentido
de mi vida es la esperanza de colombia
no podemos fallarle a la sociedad
colombiana los muertos se lo merecen los
vivos lo necesitan la vida debe ser la
base de la paz una vida justa y segura
una vida para vivir sabroso para vivir
feliz
para que la dicha y el progreso sean
nuestra identidad
cuidaré de nuestros abuelos y abuelas de
nuestros niños y niñas de las personas
con discapacidad de las personas a las
que la historia o la sociedad ha
marginado
haremos una política de cuidados para
que nadie en mayúscula se quede atrás
somos una sociedad solidaria que se
preocupa y ocupa del prójimo que su
gobierno también lo sea haremos una
política sensible al sufrimiento y al
dolor ajeno con herramientas y
soluciones para crear igualdad
gobernar con iu para las mujeres de
colombia
hoy aquí empieza un gobierno paritario
con un ministerio de la igualdad
al fin
con nuestra vicepresidenta y ministra
francia márquez vamos a trabajar para
que el género no determine cuántas
cuánto ganas ni cómo vives
queremos igualdad real y seguridad para
que las colombianas puedan caminar
tranquilas y no temer por sus vidas
dialogar con todos y todas sin
excepciones ni exclusiones
este será un gobierno de puertas
abiertas para todo aquel que quiera
dialogar sobre los problemas de colombia
se llame como se llame
venga de donde venga lo importante no es
de dónde venimos
sino a dónde vamos
nos une la voluntad de futuro no el peso
del pasado
vamos a construir un gran acuerdo
nacional para fijar la hoja de ruta de
la colombia de los próximos años
el diálogo será mi método los acuerdos
mi objetivo
5 escucharé a las colombianas y
colombianos como lo he venido haciendo
en todos estos años no se gobierna
distancia alejado del pueblo y
desconectado de sus realidades
todo lo contrario se gobierna escuchando
vamos a diseñar mecanismos y dinámicas
para que todo colombiano se sienta
escuchado en este gobierno
no quedaré atrapado entre las cortinas
de la burocracia
estaré cerca de los problemas
caminaré al lado y junto a los
colombianos de todos los rincones o la
sala me abran las casas para dormir como
el campesino cafetero de anserma como la
señora pobre de quibdó
como el pescador del río magdalena en el
tolima
solo quien está cerca puede entender y
ponerse en el lugar del otro
defenderé a los colombianos y
colombianas de las violencias y
trabajaré para que las familias se
sientan seguras y tranquilas
lo haremos con una estrategia integral
de seguridad con la seguridad humana
colombia necesita una estrategia que
vaya desde los programas de prevención
desde la redención social desde acabar
con el hambre hasta la persecución de
las estructuras criminales y la
modernización de las fuerzas de
seguridad las vidas salvadas serán
nuestro principal indicador de éxito la
seguridad se miden vidas no en muertos
cuando la seguridad se mide en muertos
llevan al estado al crimen y este estado
no está por el crimen atroz este estado
está para ser un estado social de
derecho
el crimen se combate de muchas maneras
todas imprescindibles
quiero defender a las familias
colombianas de la inseguridad diaria y
cotidiana sea de la violencia machista o
de cualquier otra violencia
lucharé contra la corrupción
con manos firmes sin miramientos
un gobierno de cero tolerancia
vamos a recuperar lo que se robaron
vigilar
para que no se vuelva a hacerlo y
transformar el sistema
para desincentivar este tipo de
prácticas
ni familia ni amigos ni
compañeros ni colaboradores
nadie queda excluido del peso de la ley
del compromiso contra la corrupción
y de mi determinación para luchar contra
ella desde hoy los cuerpos de
inteligencia del estado no perseguirán
la oposición política ni la prensa libre
ni el poder judicial ni el que piensa ni
la que piensa diferente
hoy el principal objetivo de los cuerpos
de la inteligencia del estado
es ubicar y combatir la corrupción
[Aplausos]
protegeré nuestro suelo y subsuelo
nuestros mares y ríos
nuestro aire y cielo nuestros paisajes
nos definen y nos llenan de orgullo
y por eso no voy a permitir que la
avaricia de unos pocos ponga en riesgo
nuestra biodiversidad
vamos a enfrentar
la deforestación
descontrolada de nuestros bosques e
impulsar el desarrollo de las energías
limpias y renovables
colombia será potencia mundial de la
vida
el planeta tierra es la casa común de
los seres humanos
y colombia desde su enorme riqueza
natural
va a liderar esta lucha por la vida
planetaria
desarrollar e la industria nacional la
economía popular y el campo colombiano
priorizaremos a la mujer campesina a la
mujer de la economía popular
indudablemente al microempresario y al
pequeño y mediano empresario de colombia
pero esta invitación
es a producir es a trabajar es a ser
conscientes de que sólo seremos una
sociedad rica
si trabajamos
y que el trabajo cada vez más en el
siglo 21 es una propiedad del
conocimiento del cerebro de la
inteligencia humana vamos a acompañar y
apoyar a todo aquel que se esfuerce por
colombia el campesino la campesina que
se levanta al alba el artesano la
artesana que mantiene viva nuestra
cultura el empresario la empresaria que
crea trabajo
el trabajador y la trabajadora cultural
que construye la sensibilidad de la
sociedad humana la ciencia la cultura y
el conocimiento
es el combustible verdadero del siglo 21
vamos a desarrollar la sociedad del
conocimiento y la tecnología
cumpliré y haré cumplir nuestra
constitución
la que dice en su artículo 1
abro comillas
colombia es un estado social de derecho
organizado en forma de república
unitaria descentralizada
con autonomía de sus entidades
territoriales
democrática
participativa y pluralista
fundada en el respeto de la dignidad
humana en el trabajo y la solidaridad de
las personas que la integran y en la
prevalencia del interés general
cierra comillas
desarrollaremos también una nueva
cobertura legal para ser sostenible
justo e igualitario nuestro desarrollo
la ley como dice paolo flores d'arcais
es el poder de los que no tienen poder
necesitamos mejores leyes nuevas leyes
al servicio de las grandes mayorías y
garantizar su cumplimiento
confío mucho en que los debates en
nuestro congreso de la república sea
fructífero y ofrezca resultados para la
sociedad colombiana
hay muchas tareas y confío plenamente en
los nuevos representantes de la sociedad
colombiana en el congreso
nuevos y viejos
y finalmente una idea colombia
uniremos entre todos y todas
a nuestra querida colombia
tenemos que decirle basta la división
que nos enfrenta como pueblo
yo no quiero dos países como no quiero
dos sociedades
quiero una colombia fuerte justa y unida
los retos y desafíos que tenemos como
nación
exigen una etapa de unidad y consensos
básicos
es nuestra responsabilidad